سبعه عقود منذ انطلقت الشراره الاولى
للثوره الكوبيه في يوليو تموز من عام
النصف الاول من القرن العشرين مثل للجزيره
الكاريبيه حقبه اختلفت وجوه حكامها لكنها
تشابهت في سطوه الفساد على جوانب الاداره
والاقتصاد وقوع كوبا في الحديقه الخلفيه
للولايات المتحده وضعها في بؤره الاهتمام
والقلق الامريكيين بشكل مزمن افتتح القرن
العشرون بمحاولات تدخل امريكيه صريحه في
الجزيره التي لا تبعد عن ولايه فلوريدا
سوى 145 كيلومترا ولم يناهز اوائل
الخمسينيات حتى تولى الحكم في كوبا والغين
سيو باتيستا بعد انقلاب عسكري لم يمنع
واشنطن من الاعتراف به سريعا اعتراف فتح
ابواب كوبا على اتساعها لنفوذ الشركات
الامريكيه كما تعزز الحكم الاستبدادي في
البلاد خلال تلك الفتره لم تخلوا فتره حكم
باتيستا من الفساد الذي يفترض انه قلب
لكنه اضاف اليه قبضه حديديه خنقت حريات
مواطنيه وتلك ثنائيه الفساد والاستبداد
الكفيله على الدوام بتفجير غضب الشعوب ولو
بعد حين في السادس والعشرين من يوليو عام
53 قاد الزعيم الكوبي الاشهر فيدال كاسترو
ثوره مسلحه ضد حكم باتيستا الذي فر خارج
البلاد مطلع عام 59 مصطحبا مبالغ ماليه
ضخمه لم تكن سنوات الثوره سهله لكنها
انتصرت في نهايه المطاف ممثله شوكه في
الخاصره الامريكيه وخاصه بعد اعلان كاسترو
الصبغه الاشتراكيه لنظامه صراحه عام 61 في
ذروه سنوات الحرب البارده
اوغلت واشنطن في عداء نظام الحكم في كوبا
وضربت رقما قياسيا في محاولات اغتيال
كاسترو بل دربت ودفعت 1400 كوبي معارض الى
السواحل الكوبيه للاطاحه بحكم كاسترو فيما
عرف بعمليه خليج الخنازير التي انتهت على
نحو الاحراج للبيت الابيض العداء الامريكي
القاكوبا بشكل كامل في احضان الخصم
السوفيتي الذي لم يبخل بالدعم المادي كسرا
للحصار الاقتصادي الامريكي الخانق بلغ
التحالف السوفيتي مع كوبا مستوى عسكريا
اوشك ان يفجر حربا نوويه كبرى في اكتوبر
عام 62 فيما عرف بازمه الصواريخ السوفيتيه
والتي لم تنفرج الا بصفقه بين واشنطن
وموسكو القلق الامريكي من التقارب الكوبي
مع المعسكر الشيوعي لم ينقشع بسقوط
الاتحاد السوفيتي رغم ما خلفه ذلك السقوط
من تداعيات اقتصاديه كارثيه على كوبا هل
كان يمكن لواشنطن ان تنتهج سياسه اكثر
انفتاحا مع هافانا فتكسب جارا مامون
الجانب ام ان التقارب الروسيه الكوبي لم
يدع مجالا لسياسات مختلفه لم يتبدل الموقف
الامريكي المناوي لكوبا الا ببطء شديد في
مسار توج بعوده العلاقات في عهد باراك
اوباما لكنها برهه لم تلبث ان مرت مع عهد
دونالد ترامب الذي تراجع السريعا عن خطوات
سلفه الحصار الامريكي يبقي كوبا متاخره
عقودا حتى في مظاهر الحياه اليوميه لكنه
لم يسكن القلق الامريكي من الجاره الصغيره
وما الحديث عن قاعده التجسس الصينيه في
كوبا ببعيد عن الذاكره ولا عن الذكرى
السبعين لثوره الشعب الكوبي